[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de dimanche en
politique en direct sur france 3 bons
gagner sur notre page facebook
à six semaines du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est le
regard des jeunes sur cette campagne qui
va nous intéresser aujourd'hui et pour
cela cinq invités sont réunis sur ce
plateau tout d'abord grigoire perdre son
donjon vous êtes référent des jeunes
avec macron en côte-d'or et vous
soutenez donc emmanuel macron d'avoir
non pas grégoire person c'était fou
harold lloyd ou par le bonjour ce jeu
vous êtes lee werner aussi un secrétaire
régional du front national de la
jeunesse et vous soutenez donc marine le
pen l'est où la chambre bonjour bonjour
animateur fédéral du mjs mouvement des
jeunes socialistes de côte-d'or soutien
de benoît allons florian duvernay
bonjour responsable des jeunes
républicains de saône et loire vous
soutenez donc françois fillon et clément
toulouse bonjour côte-d'or et vous
soutenez jean luc mélenchon alors selon
le dernier baromètre du cevipof le
centre de recherches politiques de
sciences po 11 % seulement des français
ont confiance dans les partis politiques
83 % pensent que le système démocratique
fonctionne plutôt mal et quand il pense
à la politique est bien les premiers
mots qui leur vient ce sont la méfiance
le dégoût et l'ennui alors expliquez
nous vous qui êtes jeunes ce qui a bien
pu vous motiver à entrer en politique et
à soutenir aujourd'hui un candidat dont
commencent par grégoire perso je suis
assez jeune moi c'est mon premier
engagement politique
j'étais un étudiant assez engagés dans
des associations solidaires ou
étudiantes et donc pour moi c'est mon
premier engagement parce que lors de
l'année dernière j'ai trouvé que
emmanuel macron était un candidat un peu
différent et que il proposait un projet
d'aller faire du porte à porte pour
écouter les français donc c'est une
façon de faire un peu plus concrète donc
c'était un peu le prolongement de mon
activité associative
donc j'ai décidé de m'engager et ça se
retrouve un peu chez les jeunes avec
macron 70% sont des primes engagé donc
c'est des gens qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude d'aller en politique et donc
c'est un peu un renouveau alors là
devant vous
bon ça fait déjà un petit moment
maintenant que vous êtes engagés en
physique mais au départ qu'est ce qui
vous a donné envie
donc dit et moi j'ai pris ma carte à me
18 ans en 2005 lors du fameux référendum
sur la constitution européenne et donc
sa mort reste un combat important et
volé poursuivis
c'était plus sur le fond vous du coup il
va sur le fond ce départ les convictions
mais aulas semble même question mais
pourquoi en politique alors que les
politiques sont tellement ali par les
français moi j'ai pas choisi de
m'engager derrière une personne mais au
contraire à m'engager pour défendre des
valeurs
et c'est comme ça que j'ai rejoint le
mouvement des jeunes socialistes parce
que finalement être de gauche c'est quoi
c'est être en capacité de s'indigner
vis-à-vis des vins justice des
inégalités et c'est ça qui a forgé
finalement mon engagement au mouvement
des jeunes socialistes laurianne dernier
numéro quand je me reconnais un peu dans
l'est dans les discours de mon camarade
moi aussi c'était pour les convictions
donc mes valeurs sont de droite et c'est
pour ça que je me suis engagé au départ
donc c'était l'ump je me suis engagé
dans l'ump
et après j'ai poursuivre l aventure avec
les américains vous n'êtes pas sourd
vous entendez toutes les critiques
envers les hommes politiques vous ça
vous a jamais arrêté en fait qu'elle
critique y avait beaucoup quand même y
en a beaucoup mais après tout ce ne sont
pas ceux liés à mon parti annonce parue
en général
donc voilà après les critiques toute
façon il y aura toujours des gens qui
vont critiquer les choses donc ça vous a
pas fait reculer du tout vous non plus
alors on renonce v 40 ans qu'on va les
mêmes politiques qui sont mises au pays
on voit ce que ça donne
et moi j'étais engagé compte dans des
luttes sociales l'année dernière contre
la loi elle comme riz ou par exemple
contre les coupes budgétaires sur
l'université du coup après ces luttes
sociales il me fallait un débouché
politique est le seul programme qui
répond aux trois urgence urgence
environnementale l'urgence sociale et
l'urgence démocratique c'est jean luc
mélenchon et les problèmes de la ccc ce
qui vous a amené finalement parce que
la lutte contre la loi elle comme brise
c'est vraiment une idée qu'il faut
déconstruire le code du travail c'est
vraiment non voir moi je suis dans le
marché du travail et je veux pas avoir à
travailler quarante huit heures par
semaine et avoir un salaire de misère
donc forcément il fallait s'engager
puisqu'on voit bien que les luttes
sociales elles ont une limite
il fallait un débouché politique je
crois pas qu'il y ait d'organisation
design dans la finance un souvenir c'est
pas une organisation de jeunes on est au
sein c'est un groupe d'appui si j'ai
l'impression d'avoir du poids vous voilà
j'aime bien sûr par exemple nous chaut
nova talent à dijon on va avoir des
candidats qui seront jeunes de moins de
30 ans et ça on le voit pas partout il y
aura la parité et des jeunes en
politique
moi par exemple je gère les réseaux
sociaux au sein de la france est soumise
on a tous des responsabilités donc non
c'est vraiment un mouvement citoyen qui
donne la place aux jeunes vous est ce
que le mjs le fmi ou quel point ils
auront finalement dans le parti on a
l'impression que c'est plus tôt voilà
pour recruter des colleurs d'affichés
des distributeurs de tracts non non pas
du tout front national les jeunes ont
une place importante depuis des années
le front national propose des candidats
jeunes regardez aux dernières élections
en bourgogne
il ya beaucoup de candidats jeunes dans
les rangs cancer anal oui exemple des
corrompus c'est lui parce que nous au
fonctionnel et on n'est pas que candidat
on peut début gégène et non y'a un tiers
des jeunes qui votent front national le
front social de la jeunesse en mouvement
qu'on dirait jeune avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'effectifs premier parti de
france chez renault mais est-ce que vous
avez votre mot à dire c'est ça que
monsieur on y regarde l'équipe de deux
campagnes l'équipe regardez le l'équipe
au sein du mouvement les gens qu'on
renvoie le doigt dans les médias et
beaucoup de jeunes il ya derrière et
david rachline il a 30 ans tente
quelques trente ans il est directeur de
campagne
oudjit s il ya eu des tensions parfois
entre le mjs et le ps mais est-ce que
vous pouvez vraiment combattre un parti
qui lance finalement le mouvement des
jeunes socialistes il a cette
particularité fait que c'est le seul
mouvement de jeunes qui est autonome et
benoît hamon en 1993 quand il était
président des jeunes socialistes
il a négocié avec le premier secrétaire
de l'époque michel rocard l'autonomie
des jeunes socialistes alors l'autonomie
c'est quoi c'est que nous élisons nos
propres
tant est que nous définissons nous même
notre propre ligne politique mais ce que
vous remontez ça au parti socialiste est
ce que vous êtes entendus au parc bien
sûr mais l'idée de l'autonomie c'est
d'abord de dire que en tant que jeune on
peut penser par nous-mêmes on n'est pas
obligé de dépendre de nos aînés vous
n'êtes pas seulement un colleur
d'affichés au sein de votre parti vous
tous si je reprends l'exemple du lors
des élections régionales avec françois
sauvadet
on nous avait demandé notamment de nous
exprimer et d'exprimer ce que nous
attendions du conseil régional donc nous
lui tous les jeunes de bourgogne franche
comté s'étaient rassemblés aussi bien
les républicains éviter pour recréer un
livret blanc en janvier on a constitué
le livret blanc a exposé plusieurs nous
on a exposé nos différentes entités et
au moins de trois sites et à nous les
jeunes qui ont été repris dans le
programme de françois sauvadet
donc bien sûr qu'on ait entendu bien sûr
qu'on participe aussi aux à l'avenir de
notre pied à l'avenir de notre région et
à maintenir notre département les jeunes
avec mc solaar séparera dans la partie
mais est-ce que plus d'autres des
organisations dans chaque département a
si j'ai bien compris
est ce que vous faites remonter des
choses est ce qu emmanuel macron vous
écouter ce que les jeunes et maquereau
en fait c'est une association qui
existait avant on marche donc le but
c'était de parler de la loi macro et
caetera et au fur et à mesure on a
continué à débattre et donc une partie
du programme d' emmanuel macron il vient
aussi de la jeunesse qui s'est exprimé
et donc c'est pas simplement d'aider de
la main d'oeuvre c'est c'est aussi des
convictions c'est des idées et les
jeunes s'expriment mais sincèrement sans
langue de bois vous avez l'impression
qu'il reçoit et qu'il entend ce que vous
dites
bah il eu un gros travail avec des
comités en france qui faisait remonter
des choses et on les retrouve dans le
programme donc à mon sens si ça
correspond à ce qu'on a on a proposé
mais qu'on le retrouve dans le programme
c'est qu'il a écoutées comme alors venez
on sort justement à cette campagne
présidentielle qui a du mal à démarrer
avec toutes toutes les affaires qui
concernent ce côté-ci de la table plutôt
mais comment vous visez ça en fait
comment vous vivez cette campagne
auteurs
c'est un concours du plus gros scandale
du plus gros conflit d'intérêts toutes
les semaines on nous dit que la
présidentielle est pliée c'est untel va
être président un tel vice président et
le lendemain il ya une affaire sur ce
sur cette personne donc vraiment on voit
qu'il ya un ras-le bol c'est s'ils sont
tous à peu près pareil et on veut que ça
change et on voit que c'est la fin d'un
régime la fin de la 5ème république où
il ya une limite à ces élus qui sont
corrompus ou qui ont des des affaires un
peu partout et voilà nous on veut que
l'on veut que ça change notamment avec
la sixième république et un
renouvellement de la classe politique y
avait un passage très délicat c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire pour votre candidat
comment vous vivez vous au quotidien
c'est facile d'aller défendre françois
fillon aujourd'hui sur les marchés
dans vos parts à port d'envaux
discussions avec vos collègues c'est
quelque chose qui est assez surprenant
parce que notamment quand on fait des
actions sur le marché
on se rend compte que les gens ne sont
pas forcément réticents françois fillon
comme on pourrait l'entendre des fois à
la télévision c'est les français je
pense qu'ils se rendent compte que
finalement ce qui est en train de se
produire ou ce qui s'est produit
notamment avec françois fillon
c'est la même chose qui s'est passé à la
dernière présidentielle avec dsk
on se rend compte qu'il était au départ
ils étaient ils étaient nommés comme le
favori
on a fait des choses pour essayer de
comment dire pour le faire descendre
public dans l'image publique et donc
voilà je pense que les français se
rendent compte c'est quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne pas et quand on dit quand
on voit différents les différents
sondages qui tombe
françois fillon n'était pas le favori
pour les primaires il les a remportées
si je prend notamment votre candidat
vont amont il n'était pas le favori il a
quand même gagné
je possède on part sur la campagne
présidentielle aux états unis trump
n'était pas non plus le favori mais
pourtant il a gagné donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment attendre
et ça ça vraiment à l'échéance qu'on va
vraiment savoir par l'association et je
pense que la campagne est très ouvert
vous êtes d'accord vous comment vous
vivez cette campagne électorale un petit
peu atypique on va dire moi j'ai pas
envie de parler des affaires moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment est ce qu'on
parle aux jeunes
aujourd'hui est ce que vous y arrivez on
y re journée aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'il ya deux tiers
des jeunes qui ne vont plus voter
et pourtant moi j'ai le sentiment que
les gens n'ont jamais eu autant envie de
s'engager dans
des associations il ya des services
civiques mais finalement les jeunes
aujourd'hui ils aspirent à une nouvelle
forme de démocratie une démocratie qui
prennent en compte réellement les
compétences des citoyens dans
l'entreprise à l'université dans la vie
politique et donnons un monde qu est-ce
qui propose lui pour répondre à tout ça
bah c'est justement la reconnaissance du
vote blanc le renforcement du rôle du
parlement ou encore le renforcement du
poids des étudiants à l'université
voilà des réponses concrètes enfin vous
assurez langue de bois quand même
compliqué cette campagne menant à lugano
vous arrivez à militer à faire valoir
les arguments d'un concours national oui
c'est ça va très bien le cette campagne
moi je me détache beaucoup des scandales
des voies de la persécution médiatique
et judiciaire encore vous persécutent
non voyant les médias et la justice sort
de son rôle façon de leur rôle que c'est
évident parce que vous vous réclamez une
espèce de trêve je judiciaire nous on
peut se dire que les son voyage en asie
voilà pourquoi je ne ferai pas une salle
émane directement de l'europe de new
york s'est donc jeté pour lui la
campagne
on oublie aussi que de chez mac rockstar
ya d'autres scandales qui plane afin de
une petite zone d'ombré se respecte
financier mais le tri ne sont pas
inquiétés pour l'instant par la justice
oui d'accord mais c'est pareil c'est une
question de temps et mais non mais vous
appréciez la campagne nous saouler
marché au contact des français on est
très bien accueilli nos idées
son centre sont reconnus sont bien
implantés nos solutions qu'on oppose
depuis des années par est ce que les
meilleurs et puis comme urgente
donc non cette campagne d'autres
difficultés
mais c'est vrai que marjolaine est le
socle solide c c
et sympathisants on va dire ce qu'ils
ont envie de voter pour elles se disent
certains d'aller voter
ça fait des années qu'on dit qu'on
alterne entre selistes les républicains
se doit de l'ump le coin des macros et
l'hologramme deux fois de françois
hollande
et puis d'ailleurs macro il ya attali
berger minc les mêmes ne gouverne depuis
des années dans le marine le pen c'est
la candidate de l'alto l'alternance du
changement c'est un changement de façade
les soutiens ça fait pas un candidat
c'est pas parce qu'on est soutenue par
un homme qui on représente cet homme
enfin c'est pas parce qu'on est soutenu
par quelqu'un que ça va changer le
candidat c'est pas parce que tout il ya
des soutiens de gauche qui est des
soutiens de droite que ça change la
ligne directrice d'un candidat à mon
sens moi macron il ay là il a un peu un
engouement chez les jeunes aussi parce
qu'il est un peu différent c'est pas un
n'est pas mieux en politique et vous sur
le terrain ça passe ça ou est-ce qu'on
vous parle sans arrêt de la campagne et
de ses affaires pas mal de jeunes nous
disent que qui ont une défiance
généralisée vers le monde politique à
cause de ses affaires à répétition parce
que on parle rarement de fond les
rarement de leurs problèmes et qui a une
espèce de déconnexion entre entre la vie
du citoyen lambda et de l'homme
politique dont les sphères vouliez
prendre la parole est aux lachenois ce
que j'entendais le front national veut
dire qu'ils étaient persécutés mais ça
c'est le vieux discours du front
national moi quand je vois vos confrères
eric sicaud qui se font sortir manu
militari des meetings du front national
je me dis est ce que c'est ça demain le
front national qui reviennent sur toutes
les libertés et notamment sur la liberté
de la presse
moi en tout cas ça m'inquiète pas de
réponse voilà avant cette émission
avant cette émission est un documentaire
un qui est passé sur les primo votants à
l'élection présidentielle et puis
l'institut ipsos a fait un sondage
auprès des jeunes marine le pen est en
tête avec 29% des intentions de vote
c'est plus que sur l'ensemble de la
population ensuite c'est emmanuel macron
qui arrive 2e 23 et demi arrive ensuite
on voit les chiffres alors là il ya un
changement par rapport à l'ensemble des
français benoît hamon 20 % jean-luc
mélenchon 14% françois fillon 10 et demi
pour cent et sur les 18 24 ans est à peu
près la même chose à quelques 10
mon prêt pourquoi marine le pen s'est
dite elle les jeunes selon lui plaide me
tourner le départ bord vers vos
adversaires pourquoi lui les jeunes
n'arrivent qu'à 40 ans qu'on ne donne
pas de l'emploi aux jeunes qu'on donne
pas une réponse aux jeunes et nous dans
notre programme par exemple on veut
donner la chance aux jeunes d'être
autonomes qu'ils aient pu besoin de la
solidarité familiale des parents des
grands parents pour vivre
on veut donner la chance par exemple il
ya un jeune sur cinq qui arrête ses
études pour des raisons financières donc
on veut donner une allocation
d'autonomie de 800 euros par mois pour
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans pendant trois
ans pour justement aider les jeunes à
avoir des formations qualifiantes pour
trouver de l'emploi et cette allocation
d'autonomie elle pourra permettre aussi
de d'enlever huit cent mille emplois
étudiants qui sont par des étudiants
salariés du coup les redonner les huit
cent mille emplois à des jeunes qui
seraient pas en étude voilà vous me
donnez l'argumentaire de jean luc
mélenchon que vous répondez pas ma
question pourquoi les jeunes ne vous
entendent pas alors qu'ils entendent
marine hôtel parce que il ya aussi sur
les médias comme une grosse position en
faveur de marine le pen et de manuels
m'apprend qu'il nous le cas où on voit
les chiffres du csa qui montre sans 16h
pour mâcon et qui montre 76 eur pour
pour marine le pen alors que nous on
n'est qu'à trente heures d'antenne sur
les chaînes donc on voit bien qu'ils
mettent en avant quand même certains
candidats jean luc mélenchon peut
s'exprimer quand même oui on peut
s'exprimer mais quand même moins que les
autres candidats et marine le pen elle
monte parce que les jeunes
or quand même aimé je pense qu'il ya
quand même 50 % des jeunes qui sont
indécis c'est ça aussi plus important ce
convoi 29% mais il y en a quand même 50
% encore qu'ils ne savent pas quoi voter
et c'est eux que j'ai encourage à aller
voter pour jean luc mélenchon
il a alors peut-être signé avec marine
le pen elle est soit accusé de par ses
détracteurs d'être la candidate du repli
sur soi est ce que ça veut dire que les
jeunes aujourd'hui il y à ce repli sur
soi bien sûr que non non je pense que
vous vous l'expliquer voilà alors je
pourrai pas là je pense que on a bien
écouté ma place sur les problèmes pour
que les votes faut pour les jeunes se
trouve le front national c'est la
désespérance des fans pas du tout c'est
que les jeunes vont très vite compris
que marine le pen c'était la solution
c'est là la vraie opportunité
il ya aussi le fait de le poids
d'internet les jeunes sa forme beaucoup
avec internet ils ont une information
qui est différente parfois de ce qu'il
voit dans les médias et se feront leurs
idées et donc du coup ils comprennent
les vrais enjeux d'avenir et se tourner
la machine appelle nos solutions que
l'on propose depuis des années pour
l'emploi des jeunes et puis l'avenir de
la france qu'on doit le les problèmes
migratoires et c est ça parle beaucoup
de jeunes et c'est logique qu'ils se
tournent vers nous c'est pas le problème
du voisin de palier qu'ils soient
musulmans créent pas une bonne couleur
de peau se passe à l'aller les jeunes
ils n'ont pas envie d'entendre ça c'est
vraiment ils veulent vivre autrement et
manger mieux et être autonome c'est seul
on va y revenir je voudrais qu'on
restait sur le sondage au centre et à
gauche et emmanuel macron qui semble
plus séduire les jeunes plutôt que
benoît hamon ou jean luc mélenchon ça va
ça vous surprend
la question à vous ce qui me concerne
c'est qu'une vraie défiance vis-à-vis
des partis politiques étaient installés
aujourd'hui front national on peut le
qualifier de parts est installé on les
connaît depuis très nombreuses années
mais finalement l'objectif de ce débat
c'est justement d'aller convaincre les
jeunes d'aller voter
mais pour ma part d'aller convaincre
d'aller voter pour benoît et benoît
hamon aujourd'hui serait le candidat du
futur désirable et notamment pour la
jeunesse une jeunesse à replier sur soi
mais notamment en quête d'avenir
benoît hamon aujourd'hui la des
propositions concrètes sur les
transformations sociales on se rend bien
compte que finalement notre modèle
social depuis afin d'être une guerre
mondiale il n'y a pas tellement changé
on a les congés payés la sécurité
sociale et pourtant lui le travail a
complètement changé aujourd'hui le
revenu universel pareil donc c'est une
réponse à aux questionnements des jeunes
c'est une véritable allocation
d'autonomie pour les jeunes moi j'ai
travaillé chez mcdo pour payer mon
logement et énormément de jeunes qui
sacrifient leurs études avec des petits
boulots étudiants aujourd'hui le revenu
universel
bah ça permet qu'un jeune se concentre
davantage sur la réussite de cette étude
plutôt de savoir comment il va pouvoir
remplir le frigo à la fin de la semaine
sur une dernière interview est revenu
sur le revenu universel et il enlève les
18 25 ans du revenu universel donc son
revenu est plus universel que tu
voudrais bien florian dujardin il ya un
déficit quand même auprès des jeunes
votre candidat comment comment vous
faites le jeu justement pour essayer de
leur degré noté sur cet électorat là
alors comme j'ai pu l'expliquer
précédemment ou c'est ce que je pense
des sondages est quand même en photo à
l'instant t
photo ne sera pas et reste encore du
temps jusqu'à l'échéance est justement
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour séduire les jeunes tout ce sont les
jeunes comme était aussi mon camarade à
ma droite et réseaux sociaux ou une
grande importance pour les jeunes et
quand on dit que les jeunes voient une
certaine information qui est différente
je ne pense pas que les jeunes sont si
aveugle et que ça les jeunes ce qui les
intéresse c'est comment va fonctionner
leur avenir plus tard
qu'est ce que ça va être leur avenir il
faut leur donner des cartes pour trouver
un emploi pour pouvoir financer ce que
les parents ou leurs grands parents qui
ont pu financer à leur époque
et là quand j'ai fait le con j'ai écouté
mes camarades tout autour de moi
personne à donner des propositions comme
tels dont café vous avez dit qu'on
allait parler dépôt comme un peu plus
tard dont il reste on y arrive avant sur
ce sondage c'est assez représentatif il
ya un espèce d'engouement quand même
pour emmanuel macron chez les jeunes
parce que c'est de la politique
autrement et parce que c'est pas et qu
est-ce qui fait autrement finalement il
n'est pas ancrée dans un parti politique
déjà c'est pas un clivage gauche
attendez c'est d'être concret réaliste
sur les choses du terrain on sait pas se
dire c'est pas une pensée dogmatique à
se dire je suis de gauche je suis de
droite alors je pense comme ça c'est le
dramatisme qui séduit un mois totalement
pourront à mon sens c'est totalement ça
c'est ce pragmatisme
je suis d'accord que le clivage gauche
droite c'est terminé on connaît
maintenant
enfin marine le pen a un problème un
programme tellement transversale que les
clivages lord bouche c'est fini et
maintenant c'est plutôt patriotes contre
mondialistes donc voilà le camp des
patriotes c'est front national et puis
battre les autres fois que vous êtes au
pouvoir c'est le camp de mondialiste de
l'union européenne de boxe thaï a
décrété pour vous il ya deux camps dans
cette campagne c'est à dire c'est qu'on
n'est pour conclure allez vous les
français auront changé de ce qui va je
ps républicain c'est fini ils ont tout
essayé pendant des décennies ça ne
marche pas la preuve est maintenant les
candidats qui émerge est passé c'est
vrai c'est que l'on marche qui est
apparemment de façade au dessus des
clivages bien que quand je disais avec
berger attali mâcon qui vient chez
rothschild etc
la banque ça change quoi on entend
beaucoup sa gauche on dit macro et à
droite et la droite ont dit que mâcon à
gauche donc au final c'est que on est à
peu près dans le vrai qu'on ne sait pas
nous placer sur l'échiquier politique
gauche droite donc c'est qu'on est
plutôt dans le vrai il n'y a pas
vraiment de deux propositions
spécifiques pour la jeunesse dans le
programmes des manuels macro bouriat
généralisée erasmus ce genre de choses
mais de jeunes qui sur par exemple
wildfire ses impasses de 500 euros pour
les jeunes à partie deux entre 18 et 25
ans qui leur permet d'accéder à de la
culture c'est un peu court pour répondre
à 80 mille logements pour les jeunes qui
sont prévus il ya des aides pour les
jeunes de qui sont dans des quartiers
permettrait leur embauche contre une
exonération de charges pour la société
c'est permettre à ces jeunes qui sont
dans des quartiers par exemple qui
peuvent pas trouver d'emploi en dehors
de leur quartier etc qui sont un peu a
signé dans leur quartier de pouvoir
sortir des fins cdc concret c'est c'est
sûr que ça fait partie d'un projet
global il n'y a pas que la jeunesse
c'est dans un projet global
c'est permettre aux jeunes d'avoir une
meilleure éducation des meilleures
formations
de re développer l'apprentissage et
l'alternance et c'est concret alors vous
tout à l'heure vous parlez du revenu
universel
vos détracteurs vous savez ce qu'ils
disent et lisbonne
tout à l'heure vous parliez du mcdo
quand on a besoin de financer ses études
mais en même temps les utilisent voilà
on va on va faire en sorte que ces
jeunes n'ai plus envie d'aller bosser
avec ça non aujourd'hui la question du
revenu universel fait pouvoir rendre les
jeunes autonomes financièrement la
question elle est là à l'est est ce
qu'un jeune aujourd'hui doit sacrifier
ses études en est on connaît les
chiffres du salariat étudiant on voit
bien à quel point ça pénalise les jeunes
dans leurs études donc sa défection
c'est une réponse concrète mais après
plus globalement benoît hamon ces
candidats du futur désirable
il est pas là à dire pour les jeunes va
faire si on va faire simple le faire
soit il part du principe que les jeunes
globalement ils peuvent avoir confiance
aussi du modèle de société dans lequel
ils veulent grandir quand on parle de
futur désirable par exemple c'est aussi
des questions écologiques
nous on a parti une génération où les
perturbateurs endocriniens n'ont jamais
été aussi présents ou la pub les cas de
puberté ont jamais été aussi précoce que
des cancers donc jamais touché autant
les jeunes et benoît hamon lui il a des
réponses concrètes pour répondre à ces
enjeux là parce qu'un futur désirable
ça passe aussi par ça pour vous le futur
désirable
florian des vernets il passe par quoi
parce que alors je précise que le
programme de françois fillon n'est plus
sur son site internet après ce qui doit
le présenter et doit présenter une
version remaniée demain qu'est ce qui
vous a séduit vous particulièrement pour
pour les jeunes
quand j'entends les personnes autour de
cet homme à chaque fois on parle de tête
on parle de deux salaires et universel
c'est l'assistanat ce que ce que veulent
les jeunes c'est vraiment des cartes
pour pouvoir assurer leur avenir
notamment françois fillon durant son
programme d lorsqu'il a explosé son
programme des primaires a expliqué qu'il
fallait qu'on rapproche
l'étudiant au monde de l'entreprise doit
développer l'entrepreneuriat déjà dans
des chalets je vais raconter une
anecdote personnelle jusqu'à la licence
mon bac + 3 j'ai été à 100% 100 % à
l'école et j'ai décidé de faire mon
master en alternance
je vais vous dire que quand j'ai
commencé mon manette mon master en
alternance quand je suis arrivé pour la
première point de l'entreprise ça m'a
fait un chez lui un grand fossé qui
s'est passé maintenant aujourd'hui le
gros problème qui se passe c'est que les
jeunes et ça c'est un ça dure déjà
depuis un bon bout de temps il y à un
décalage entre le monde de l'entreprise
le monde du travail c'est à dire le
monde que la une personne qui arrive qui
né en france va vivre le plus de temps
donc il ya un sacré fossé entre ce qu'on
nous apporte la théorie est là et le
concret vous avez parlé de concret tout
à l'heure j'ai pas vu le concret dans ce
que vous disait le plus important c'est
que le monde sait que les gens c'est que
les jeunes ont déjà une appréhension
dans le monde qui vont vivre dans le
monde professionnel qui vivent twitter
dans lequel ils vont travailler une
question à un rôle blanot qu'elle est
quelles sont les mesures finalement qui
ont des petits peuvent séduire les
jeunes fait marine le pen est bien déjà
très large la préférence nationale à
l'emploi aux aides sociales
beaucoup de jeunes comprennent que la
pause nationale passer une opportunité
se garder leurs acquis sociaux pour eux
et parler de lui dilapidé on dira aux
migrants etc qui font tenir compte de la
concurrence du dumping social
ensuite pour les gamins à l'université
et à remettre la méritocratie plus de
sélections au tirage au sort c'est un et
il ya un emploi jeune le pour les 18 21
ans dispositif premier emploi la fatigue
des français calmement toulouse il
parlait qu'il a pu faire sa licence à
100% dans sa licence mains moi par
exemple j'ai pas la chance de a d'être à
100% dans mes études je suis je suis
obligé d'aller à travailler à côté on
est plein de voir travailler 10 heures
18 heures par semaine et on peux pas
être à cent pour cent dans les études et
du coup on ne peut pas bayadh et il ya
une augmentation de l'échec en licence
quand on est étudiant salarié donc faut
bien faut bien donner les moyens aux
jeunes de pouvoir faire des formations
qualifiantes et du cru ça passe par une
allocation d'autonomie de 800 euros par
mois pour tous les jeunes
je sais pas parce que j'ai fait ma
licence à 100% à l'école et que j'ai pas
été en alternance vous en entendez ce
que je n'ai pas travaillé je veux
travailler les week-ends à ce moment là
allez je vous dis
je vous donne 10 secondes à chaque homme
et pas plus qu'elle serait la première
mesure si votre candidat parce que vous
voudriez voir appliqué à les voir bah
pour moi c'est d'aider les salariés les
plus précaires c'est à dire il ya une
baisse des charges patronales qui
permettrait et salariales qui
permettrait à chacun de gagner plus de
100 euros par mois en plus albano en
guise bout la révision de la
constitution même pas 10 novembre à
l'achat de leur revenu universel comme
disait notre camarade de florian ou
clément ils en ont eu besoin d'en
lorsque l'arrêté toit en licence et toi
aujourd'hui parce que tu es obligé de
travailler pour financer ses études
comédien jeunes de trouver leur place
dans le monde de l'entreprise et
notamment le salaire universel j'en ai
pas eu besoin puisque je travaillais le
week-end des 9 au cou parler des
étudiants moi c'est pour les hommes
jeunes agriculteurs on veut tripler le
nombre d'agriculteurs pour une refonte
du modèle agricole pour une agriculture
plus biologique et plus précise anne est
du coup donné les moyens jeunes de de se
poser ok merci merci à tous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ça passe très
vite je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
voir ou revoir cette émission sur notre
site internet ou sur notre page facebook
tout de suite place l'info régionale
avec sébastien kérou dimanche en
politique continue juste après et
francis letellier reçoit aujourd'hui le
sénateur maire de lyon gérard collomb
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]